we look at blockchain as solving human
trust issues that cause
inefficiency and so if you have
multiple parties for example that are
trying to collaborate and work together
you always have
inefficiency due to a lack of trust and
now you can actually solve those
issues with blockchain right welcome to
20 minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc found in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomitech and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring opposed labs and hillel at
stanford finally we're talking about
blockchain
meet ali madawji managing partner at
blockchain founders fund
which invests in and venture builds top
tier startups
he is a limited partner on loyal vc and
draper goran home
ali consults organizations on emerging
technologies such as insead and the un
on solutions to help alleviate poverty
he is a senior blockchain fellow at
insead and was recognized as a
blockchain 100 global leader
by lattice 80. ali madhav ji thank you
so much for joining me on 20 minute
leaders all the way from mexico how are
you
great thanks so much michael for having
me on the show
i am incredibly excited to have you here
uh not just because you're an expert in
blockchain but i think that you the
whole
your whole journey you know just sifting
through the vast experiences that you've
had
specifically in the blockchain space
both on an entrepreneurial perspective
but also on an
investors and advisory perspective i
think is completely phenomenal
and and i'm excited to to both dive deep
into the blockchain as an industry
but also understand how it may be
relevant for young entrepreneurs and
and executives around the world just
even framing our mind
as to what the heck is happening less
than 24 hours if i believe that tesla
announced
a you know their investment into the
bitcoin space
and so obviously it's taking over the
world by a storm
but now i'm excited to learn truly why
ali welcome tell me a little bit about
yourself and how do you get started with
blockchain
absolutely so thanks again for having me
on here and uh excited to be chatting
about blockchain and
you know where we really see this
technology going
i mean i've been in this space for for
quite a while originally
more passively you know holding bitcoin
and and then early coins like ethereum
and uh and then decided in 2016 to jump
in as an entrepreneur into the space
uh and as i was finishing my my mba
insead i was i was already working
full-time on a startup
uh exited that at the end of 2017 which
worked out to be pretty good timing
uh given sort of what happened
afterwards and
uh and and since then we started
blockchain founders fund and scalex
ventures
we now have uh well over 45 portfolio
companies in the venture program
we also invested in several other funds
like loyal vc where we're on the
investment committee
as well as draper goren home which is
one of tim draper's uh
funds on the blockchain side uh so also
an lp on that
and uh and it's been fantastic there's
well over a a hundred and fifty
portfolio companies across
across all of that and uh and it's been
an incredible journey
and uh and you know what really drives
me at the end of the day is
working with incredibly brilliant
entrepreneurs who are
passionate and put you know blood sweat
and tears
into making the world a better place and
and you know helping the world to
benefit from
you know the innovation the passion the
change that they're really trying to
drive in
and so it's i have i think uh one of the
best jobs in the world being able to
just
work with people like that i love that
and actually right before we started i
asked you
i assume that you're not you know
originally based out of mexico and you
mentioned that you're actually
a traveler full-time and uh and i think
that that's
uh that's obviously a dream for many
many people do you wake up
some people call it you know some people
call it homeless some people say i
travel full-time
you know it's uh it's a it's a small
distinction maybe
very thin line do you wake up one day
and say i'm gonna go into the blockchain
space and i'm gonna become
an expert in blockchain both as an
entrepreneur as an investor and advisor
is that what happened or
or is there some transition or train of
thought as you
unravel what what's happening
yeah no i absolutely not definitely did
not
uh think of sort of this uh this path in
that way right
for me what really happened is as i
started getting exposed to
space i started spending nights uh
and days just you know talking to people
that were already involved in the space
really diving deeper having those really
you know almost philosophical
discussions on where we see the world
and what
what it should be like um and then being
on a lot of
you know forums things like that really
trying to understand
you know where where and what this
technology is doing and if it
uh has the potential almost to help
bring the world in
in the direction that we maybe
idealistically
or naively see it and and where it
should be right and so
that was probably the the main
catalyst um and and i think
at that time it was still very different
to where the world is today right you're
seeing a lot of
maybe cracks in the systems i would
almost call it
in you know how we see this almost
uncontrollable government printing
that's happening right now
and and inflation i mean i i personally
don't
look at that any different from
just taking money out of your bank
account right because everyone works
hard for their money
and if you're inflating the amount of
money it's just it's no different than
just taking money out of your bank
account or just making your money worth
less like
it it's the same thing it's just
different flip sides of the same coin
and and it's kind of crazy and that's
just on
say on on that aspect right um
i know you asked the question on where
or or why it's sort of important like
why does blockchain
sort of matter what should entrepreneurs
think about it and
the way that we look at that right is
we look at blockchain as solving human
trust issues that cause inefficiency
and so if you have multiple parties for
example that are trying to collaborate
and work together you always have
inefficiency due to a lack of trust
and now you can actually solve those
issues with blockchain right
and there's already a lot of examples
and of course then you have the
philosophical discussion of like private
blockchain public but but
you know you can sort of ignore all of
that right um
i mean at a sort of basic level but if
you're solving these human trust issues
you can
take examples that exist from even large
corporates i don't know
say you know walmart walmart
has you know obviously thousands and
thousands of suppliers and if you take
sort of
what they're doing um you know they're
tracking for example different products
so like one example that they have
fully live right now is tracking um
food products so say like mango so
sliced mango so they track this between
south america and north america
and they've now cut down the time
because there's 50
suppliers essentially in the middle
you've got you know everything from
farmer
to you know picking planting cutting
you know packaging you know all the
different middlemen for transportation
all the way to getting to the end store
it used to take them
seven days to understand you know and be
able to trace through all those systems
where it actually came from where did
that product come now it takes some 2.2
seconds
and so you can see because you're
bringing everyone on to you're solving
this sort of trust issue
all these multiple system issues you can
actually create a lot of efficiency and
this is
you know across a lot of different
industries but that's just one example
because a lot of people also
generally don't see live solutions it's
still a lot very
a lot of people talk about this industry
very theoretically
right and i think ellie that's that's
really i think something that i could
get a lot of help with
because you know i remember let's say
four or five years ago everybody was
talking about mining bitcoin right that
was the term that everybody's throwing
around you have a computer
wow you should be mining bitcoin right
now and i don't know what the heck that
means right and and
you know time goes on and blockchain
becomes more
i start hearing about it more in the
context of an industry and an ecosystem
and now there's venture capital
investors that are dedicated to this
there's more different types of coins
that are that are hitting the market
right i believe if i go on robin hood
now there's a bunch of different
cryptocurrencies that i could invest in
and now you have the elon the likes of
elon musk coming and saying
uh saying you know this is the future
can you walk me through a brief history
lesson
over how what happened in the past few
years
that really made blockchain so central
to today and
from your interpretation where do you
think we're headed and i'm asking as a
young entrepreneur that i'm trying to
wrap my head around like where am i in
this whole ecosystem that i
still barely understand yeah so i i
think there's
several sort of interesting angles to
look at it on
right so you've got the cryptocurrency
industry which i think
you know has obviously there's still a
lot like i mean you hear a lot of the
negative stuff about this industry and
here's some of the positive stuff but
you know cryptocurrency is one part that
i think is fascinating from
from a number of angles but one you know
bitcoin
of course being a finite resource in a
world where
you know printing of money is you know
essentially
unlimited from their words not not even
mine
and from the perspective that gold in
in reality is essentially
infinite as well in some certain cases
depending on how you look at it
um but if you factor in a long-term
perspective of
humans will evolve with technology and
be
you know more present in space and space
mining will exist well
you've got 92 billion dollars of gold
per person on earth
right and so you can essentially just
discount cash flow back
that calculation whether you think
that's 50 years 500 years 5000 years
doesn't matter
you know bring it back to present it's
an infinite number so
um so that that essentially is
is a a a part where gold as well is not
a
finite asset uh in reality or at least
the way we would sort of typically
conceive
and so bitcoin you know creates a lot of
value then from just
being uh what people are are putting
essentially into it which is trust of it
being a finite
uh wait i mean not trust of it being it
is a finite asset but trust that
it is an alternative to the current
system
um in reality trust is still a big part
of it and it's a collective trust right
so can you explain to me a little bit
about how that trust is being built
because
obviously you know the whole assumption
behind blockchain is this idea of
validating it constantly this constant
validation this constant agreement
between a lot of parties which makes it
much harder to
compromise and and and is not
centralized in in
any way shape or form like banks are so
can you demystify it a little bit
for me now really what is it in the
essence why is it more trustworthy
and and then all i'd love to move on
hearing a little bit about your activity
as an investor in the space and and how
startups can find themselves
entering this ecosystem yeah so i mean i
i don't want to i guess make this uh too
complex right
um but you know if you sort of look at
it you've got
a lot of different parties um
essentially that are helping to secure
the system so
all around the world they don't know
each other necessarily
um and that creates essentially the
um the certainty that
all of the transactions then are are
validated not manipulated versus
the alternative to that would be like um
you know
you you're a corporation you have your
one system
no one else can really see it and then
you're sort of you know telling the
public
like what those numbers really are right
and so this is why like then auditors
exist
other parties exist to check your books
but it's still not to the level of say
fully decentralized right and you've had
issues with this then right so you've
had
issues of trust against public companies
and runs an example others where
you know because there was no lack of
understanding
uh and third party validation you then
had issues
and an example again would be like i
don't know validating like oil
reserves or other things right if there
was multiple third parties
and then the data couldn't be
manipulated and couldn't be changed like
you then have more safety and security
right and
and i don't want to go too complex so
i'm trying to try to make it a little
bit more
basic um and so so bitcoin's network
then
is much more secure just because it's
decentralized nature
right right um and
and that's sort of more on the the
crypto i mean that's a mix of crypto and
blockchain but we sort of talked about
bitcoin reality um if you look at
the corporate world and how they're
using blockchain is very interesting
as part of solving those inefficiencies
due to human trust that i sort of
mentioned earlier
and that's quite interesting because
you've already got players that have
fully live solutions like walmart right
and
we didn't even touch it i mean depending
on where your audience is from i mean
some might be aware of like food safety
issues
uh and outbreaks right so i mean in
china you had
the melamine scandal with uh tainted
milk right
i think there was 300 000 sick babies uh
in europe you had the the tainted horse
meat scandal
where i think in upwards of 13 or or
more countries in
in europe they were selling uh horse
meat uh but it was labeled as beef right
it took
four plus years for interpol to get to
the bottom of it if you look at
north america you have the chipolte
mexican grill scandal which costed
billions of dollars in shareholder value
however if you could just trace to the
bottom of your suppliers easily
you wouldn't have these issues so that
this is where it's transforming
industries like that
as an example um
and and you're already seeing it right i
mean
uh in china for example walmart schools
have fifty percent of all fresh meat
40 of vegetables and 12.5 percent of
seafood on blockchain
uh you know quite shortly so there's
pretty aggressive goals and some of that
can get delayed with the pandemic but
um there's pretty aggressive goals and a
very clear
roi to it right hsbc's moved well over a
trillion dollars on their blockchain for
fx settlements for example and they've
saved
over 25 over their traditional fx
settlement process right so
you have a lot of different benefits um
and clear rois
on this sort of stuff um and so you know
you gotta look at what are the real
examples of what's happening out there
as well on the blockchain side as well
as understanding that you know what's
happening on the crypto side
and so yeah i mean that that's a little
bit of a
an idea of a progress being made in the
space
and so now as as a young entrepreneur
myself and to the
pre-series a perhaps uh founders that
are following this
what are some things that we should be
keeping in mind because honestly i am
far behind on i'm doing my homework for
blockchain and i feel that i'm already
behind
on this material but what what do i need
to be doing in order to prepare myself
for this emerging industry
in this ecosystem you know whether i'm
infintic or not how how is how am i
going to be
met with blockchain you know along the
next few years
yeah it's i mean it's a good question
and blockchain goes across a lot of
different industries right so it's not
just
intact it's it's going to touch you know
all sorts of industries and already is
right um in reality i
i think you know we we look at companies
across
all sorts of sectors a big chunk of our
companies for blockchain we have a lot
of companies that are actually
non-blockchain as well that are emerging
tag
and i think the big thing is it's
important to understand these trends
understand these technologies
see if it makes sense for for your
business um
you know but at the end of the day as
well like you can't be
you know going down this road if it's
not creating
you know major amount of core strategic
value as an early stage startup
um it probably then doesn't make sense
to to use this technology
if it's not the core value add for your
end consumer right so
or your customer so uh i mean the big
thing at the end of the day
i think is just figure out what's going
to drive the most amount of value for a
customer that's understanding and having
discussions on like
pain points you know value that they're
looking for
what they're trying to solve etc or what
what you can solve based on
understanding their challenges
and then taking all of that and figuring
out you know what is the best way to
solve it and then
you know what is the path to solving
that look like because it's not always
linear
and and if you do that that's that's
probably the best stages and then when
you get to
you know your pre-series a or series a
i'm sure you'll have some questions on
from all sorts of investors on any sorts
of technologies like ai
you know machine learning blockchain all
sorts of stuff and
and just being aware of it you can you
can answer those questions
understand if that fits into your
roadmap or not et cetera
that makes that makes a lot of sense ali
we just have a few minutes left but
i really want to thank you for taking
the time to be here i know how busy you
are and
how involved you are with the ecosystem
and i appreciate you sharing you know
just a sliver of of all the insights and
information that you have
i i want to know what what gets you so
excited about blockchain why are you
dedicating your whole self to this
whether it's advising the united nations
or contributing to all these different
publications work with working with all
these companies
what is it about this ecosystem or this
industry that really gets you excited
that's a great great question i do spend
a lot of my time
uh you know in this sector as you
mentioned you know working with the
united
nations working with institutions like
insead uh which is
you know another leading business school
out there
and and at the end of the day it's
really understanding how this technology
is solving some of the biggest
challenges
we have as we continue to move into a
digital world right so
an innately digital way of digital
transactions right
it makes a lot of sense um you know
solving those trust issues that we
talked about
in a business world that's going to
unlock a lot of value
and so we're seeing this really from an
roi
perspective when we look at how this
technology is going to continue to
transform
and impact different sectors as with
other technologies you take that and you
pair it with
you know ai we look at an exponential
increase in value from the convergence
of technologies
and having them move together right and
and these are really really big things
because
blockchain alone doesn't really solve
that much if you're not pairing it with
other technologies that create you know
that amplification uh
you know as part of the solution that
makes a lot of sense and
i have to say that after this i it just
sparks my curiosity
to dive to just dive deeper and i have
to see what you're doing with with your
fund
and the different companies you're
involved with because i feel uh
definitely after this episode that i'm
lacking behind even if i'm not you know
personally
working on blockchain i think that it's
it's something that you know we all have
to have
at least a fundamental understanding of
and how it's going to meet us and what
responsibility do we have
as a part of this ecosystem because it's
here to stay and so
it's now part of it's a part of our
reality uh ali i really appreciate you
coming here i have the hardest
and most fun question before we end
which is three words that you would
choose to describe yourself
that's a that's a really good question i
mean i would start off with
work ethic uh change and
passion and uh and and
yeah and at the end of the day i think
for for any entrepreneur
it's really going out there and working
harder than
anyone else around you and then
surrounding yourself with great people
and just having the passion
to change the world i love it i love it
ali thank you so so much
stay safe stay healthy enjoy your time
in mexico and i'm gonna catch you on one
of your
world trips to continue picking your
brain so thank you very much
sounds good always happy to chat take
care
[Music]